e aí
e o que vocês diriam se soubessem que o
governo brasileiro acaba de comprar um
sistema inteligente de prevenção ao
crime
e o sistema vai funcionar integrado as
câmeras de monitoramento dessas que já
estão espalhadas por toda a cidade tipo
que a gente vê na saída do metrô o
sistema vai receber as imagens de vendas
dessas câmeras fazer reconhecimento
facial e nos identificar vai verificar
se o nosso comportamento recente combina
com comportamento de um criminoso
potencial prestes a cometer um delito e
aí dá uma chance para polícia poder
evitar o crime
e o sistema prende esse perfil de
comportamento criminoso das bases de
dados da receita da polícia você acorda
no sábado pronto para assistir à final
do campeonato seu time vai jogar você já
se consideram campeão comprou todo o
material do churrasco para celebrar no
final do jogo está feio para o jogo de
percebe que faltou comprar o álcool para
acender a churrasqueira olha no relógio
ainda dá tempo resolvi passar um
supermercado senão no supermercado vai
pegar a garrafa de álcool não resiste a
promoção leve 4 pague 3 coloca as 4
garrafas de álcool no carrinho mas caixa
de fósforo e no caminho para o caixa
pega aquela aquela facão bem afiado
pensando confio em você vai cortar a sua
picanha paga tudo no cartão deixa as
coisas em casa e segue para o jogo na
saída do metrô
o abordado por um policial que te
convida a prestar depoimento na
delegacia mais próxima o sistema
inteligente concluiu que você é um
arruaceiro potencial prestes a jogar um
coquetel molotov na torcida
em uma delegacia você até parece tudo
mas até tudo ficar bem esclarecido você
já perdeu o seu jogo de futebol isso
parece sendo a saída de filme de ficção
científica combinado com comédia mas não
é o brasil ainda não tem esse tipo de
sistema mas a china essa já tá usando o
sistema de prevenção de crimes em várias
cidades estados unidos e inglaterra
estudam uso dessa tecnologia para baixar
criminalidade
e a inteligência artificial não é uma
tecnologia do futuro ela já está
presente aqui sendo muito usada por nós
às vezes a gente nem sente
e eu garanto que cada um aqui hoje usam
um sistema inteligente sempre perceber
quem é que não pagou alguma conta com
cartão de crédito
ah pois é quando você pagou o cartão de
crédito um sistema inteligente foi
acionado para verificar se a sua compra
já de acordo com seu padrão de consumo
de forma semelhante o aplicativo de
transporte que você usou também acionam
o sistema inteligente para escolher um
carro que melhor se ajustasse às suas
preferências o motorista desse carro os
um sistema inteligente para obter uma
rota que mais rápido te trouxesse até
aqui para mim assistir
e eu trabalho inteligência artificial há
mais de 30 anos já desenvolvi muito e
sistemas inteligente meu primeiro
emprego quando sair da escola de
engenharia foi num grupo de inteligência
artificial de uma grande empresa de
telecomunicações me apaixonei depois eu
tiro a chance de fazer meu doutorado na
universidade stanford na califórnia um
dos melhores centros de inteligência
artificial do mundo mas afinal o que é
inteligência artificial
e a inteligência artificial é programar
a máquina para ser capaz de realizar
tarefas que demandam habilidades
associadas à inteligência humana por
exemplo ser capaz de se comunicar
conosco na nossa linguagem como fazem os
nossos assistentes pessoais dos nossos
celulares sabia perceber e interpretar o
mundo como no reconhecimento de imagem
dos carros autônomos poder planejar
sequência de atividades para alcançar
metas como de sistemas inteligentes que
saibam jogar xadrez saber raciocinar
para resolver problemas complexos como
sistemas inteligentes de diagnóstico
médico e é claro aprender a fazer tudo
isso sozinha
essa é a máquina prendi aprende se der
mussarela sequência de passos para ela
poder agir como a gente aprende nos
livros e também se der uns ela um
conjunto de exemplos pela se guiar assim
como nós aprendemos coisas experiências
da vida e assim a máquina vai ter o
estilo de raciocínio a personalidade e o
conhecimento que estão dentro desses
exemplos a inteligência da máquina é o
modelo matemático sufisticado que
inspirado na nossa arquitetura cerebral
é a máquina prendi ajustando os
parâmetros desse modelo sozinha até
chegar uma configuração que melhor
responda os exemplos aquela foi exposta
e aí aqui está o perigo eu quero chamar
atenção de vocês para 3 características
das bases de dados que conduzem o
aprendizado da máquina
é a primeira característica é que não
existe base de dados neutra as bases de
dados onde contém registros de escolhas
humanas por exemplo quando você vai ao
médico o médico decide o que que vai
escrever na sua ficha e é isso que a
máquina pode ver
e quando eu era pequenininha bem
bonitinha minha avó achava que eu podia
ser miss na verdade a minha irmã é quem
foi mesmo - barra do piraí minha cidade
natal
é isso sempre ficou no meu subconsciente
com uma coisa folclórica até que em 2016
eu me deparei com projeto que despertou
minha curiosidade era um concurso de
beleza online em que os juízes eram
robôs baseados em sistemas inteligentes
os robôs aprender um conceito de belo de
fotos de mulheres lindíssimas que se foi
apresentado
e não haveria a marmelada participará
simples você mandava uma foto sem
photoshop é claro e participava o
concurso foi bem abrangente mais de 6
mil candidatas de quase 100 países
o que é o resultado esse foi controversa
as 44 ganhadores é uma mulheres brancas
e é claro que todos nós conhecemos
mulheres negras lindíssimas e aí que que
aconteceu afinal
e olhando a gente se vê que foi algo que
a gente devia ter esperado as fotos
entregues para o computador é um dia
atrizes hollywood o nas que na época em
sua grande maioria eram mulheres brancas
olha o nosso viés sendo passado para
máquina ela vai aprender as bases não
são neutras tá certo que a gente pode
viver sem um concurso de beleza mas há
várias outras tarefas sendo auxiliados
por esses temas em que as consequências
podem ser muito grave pra gente já
juízes usando sistemas inteligentes para
auxiliar na decisão sob liberdade
condicional os sistemas aprendem das
bases de casos de reincidência o creme
se você já podem imaginar os vieses
raciais que estão aparecendo nada essas
são consequências muito mais graves do
que ser preterida por um concurso de
beleza
e aí
é a segunda característica que eu quero
chamar atenção de vocês é que eu
conhecimento nas bases de dados tem
validade o que era verdade no passado
pode não ser mais aplicável no presente
isso a gente tem que verificar só dar um
exemplo em meados de 2018 uma grande
empresa de comércio eletrônico resolveu
ampliar o seu processo seletivo sabendo
que a receber muitos currículos resolveu
investir num sistema inteligente para
fazer uma pré-seleção
e o sistema de aprender data enorme base
de casos de funcionários
o sistema foi desenvolvido e utilizado e
o resultado foi parar nas páginas dos
jornais
o preconceito contra nós mulheres
nenhuma mulher foi pré-selecionada mas
nenhum homem que estudou em escola com
nome de mulher foi selecionado mas
afinal o que aconteceu não era a
intenção da empresa
a empresa só esqueceu que a presença
feminina na área de computação é recente
então a base de funcionários que ela
tinha era majoritariamente masculina
então os homens se davam bem é porque na
sua grande maioria eram homens
e olha aí novamente a validade tem um
papel importante
e a terceira característica que eu quero
chamar atenção de vocês é que às vezes
os dias estão escondidos nos dados e aí
é muito difícil de detectar a luz vejo
que aconteceu recentemente publicado em
o tubo de 2019 agora sobre um viés
racial e sistema inteligente na área de
saúde
em uma grande empresa de seguro de saúde
americana notou que a maioria dos seus é
assegurados com doenças crônicas graves
estavam entrada com muita frequência em
sistemas de emergência e usavam muito
centro de tratamento intensivo esses são
procedimentos muito caros aí resolveu
investir em um tratamento preventivo tá
bom e daria esse tratamento preventivo
uma vez que isso também incorre em
gastos aos pacientes considerados
críticos bom é onde consideraram que um
paciente era considerado crítico se ele
usava mais o seguro saúde tendo as
mesmas condições clínicas fair se você é
igual ao outro parceiro tá com as mesmas
situações clínicas mas tenho mais a
médico tá fazendo mais exame tomando
mais remédio que você tá pior
e não resolveu focar nesses nesses
pacientes para que não houvesse viés
racial tirou qualquer informação sobre
esse assunto
e o sistema foi implementado implantado
e ficou em uso de 2013/2015 uma pesquisa
em vezes investigando os resultados no
tuc majoritariamente esses tratamentos
preventivos eram oferecidos os pacientes
brancos mas afinal o computador nem
conhecia essa variável o que aconteceu
será que os brancos são mais frágeis uma
investigação mais aprofundada viu que
não era nada disso na verdade os negros
eram mais pros pobres e não podiam pagar
a contrapartida exigida pelo seguro lá o
seguro não cobre tudo então por exemplo
se uma consulta é sem reais o seguro
cobre 80 e você tem que desenbolsar 20
além disso os negros não queriam perder
dias de trabalho com medo justificável
de perder o emprego
g1
e olha como foi difícil identificar esse
viés e o que chama a atenção de vocês
que esses exemplos de vieses tem na
verdade criado um esforço grandes na
comunidade acadêmica tentando resolver
esse problema a inteligência artificial
é poderosa ela é como uma criança
esperta que a súmula tudo que lhe é
apresentado porém sem ainda capacidade
de análise crítica inerentes e seres
humanos adultos verificar se o que foi
apreendido está de acordo com que a
considerado éticos nas sociedades cabe a
nós exigirmos das empresas e dos
governos que esses sistemas inteligentes
sejam transparentes e o detalhe weiss
e afinal todos queremos usufruir dos
benefícios dessa tecnologia nós não
queremos é ser vítimas dos vieses e
preconceitos humanos consolidados pelo
aprendizado de máquina
mas voltando ao nosso exemplo do jogo de
futebol é claro que queremos cidades
mais seguras ea inteligência artificial
tem um papel importante na prevenção o
creme que nós não podemos admitir é
perdemos o jogo do nosso time do coração
porque um robô tomou uma decisão enviada
obrigada
e aí